turning to donald trump's legal troubles
the former president has now taken his
first legal action to challenge that fbi
search at mar-a-lago
this comes after we learned just how
severe his situation may be there is a
new report that hundreds of classified
records have already been taken from the
former president since january
robert costa is following all of this he
is in palm beach florida this morning
bob good morning
good morning david the former
president's 21-page motion is not just a
legal move but a political argument it
claims he is the front-runner for the
republican nomination in 2024 and cast
the investigation in political terms the
justice department's response this is
not political
two weeks after the fbi search of his
mar-a-lago home former president trump
is asking a federal court in florida to
stop federal investigators from
reviewing the documents taken until a
special master or third party attorney
can be appointed in the legal filing he
also requests that the fbi return any
documents that went beyond the scope of
the search warrant a special master
would be almost like an extra judge to
take an independent look at those the
filing also reads as a political pitch
ahead of a possible run in 2024 in which
trump's lawyers make unsubstantiated
claims of investigators being partisan
saying law enforcement cannot be used as
a weapon for political purposes and go
on to say that the matter at hand
involves not only the constitutional
rights of president trump but also the
preservation of executive privilege
national security lawyer bradley moss by
admitting this is really all just about
executive privilege donald trump is
admitting these are official records not
personal records this filing was all
about trying to shore up his position
with the republican base and hoping that
no one notices it's not properly
constructed is going to get slammed by
the judge so far a u.s official tells
cbs news that the justice department has
retrieved at least 150 classified
documents from the boxes trump handed
over to the national archives earlier
this year in the new york times reports
that since federal agents re-engaged
with trump's legal team this summer and
then searched his home that number has
climbed with more than 300 documents
with classified markings obtained by the
justice department i personally approve
the decision to seek a search warrant in
this matter the justice department
released this statement after the motion
was filed monday saying the search was
authorized by a federal court upon the
required finding of probable cause while
the former president continued to rail
against the search he called a break-in
all he knows is to throw things at the
wall and to try to file various motions
or lawsuits to try to delay things it's
worked for him in the past what the
problem he's got here is it's a criminal
investigation a grand jury has been
convened federal prosecutors already had
to get a search warrant for his property
that's something he's never faced before
this all comes as a florida federal
judge prepares to decide this week
whether to release a redacted version of
the affidavit that led to the fbi surge
of the mar-a-lago estate that affidavit
could reveal more about why fbi agents
went in and why they believe a crime
might have been committed tony
yeah and if there were 300 documents
marked classified there at mar-a-lago
four months bob thank you very much